[Music]
all right first on all this is proximity
this one's pretty good yeah we actually
uh we had i hadn't heard anything about
this one and we just like saw it when we
were scrolling through the new releases
on
the xbox rental thing and uh it looked
like we watched the trailer
this is interestingly one of the few
movies that i've seen where
the movie was actually much better than
the trailer led me to believe i mean the
trailer looked like a good interesting
movie
but the trailer almost made it look more
like
a drama about somebody who
may or may not have been abducted by
aliens
but then when you watch the actual movie
it's like some of it is like that
but on the whole it's actually like kind
of a fun
80s throwback like sci-fi adventure
that has like a lot of action or
elements to it it had like um lots of
lucas
yeah it was very very george lucasy
which i didn't really get the
sense of that from the trailer so i was
actually really pleasantly surprised
like when i watched it like it was a lot
better than i was expecting
yeah it was like it was basically star
wars thx 1138 it had like close
encounters of the third kind
yeah very much like that it had like uh
like a
williams style classical score to it
sounded straight out of [ __ ] star
wars indiana jones yeah
the dagobah and [ __ ] scenes and then it
would break off
break out into like rock music and
electronic music and stuff
just so it was a weird mixture of like
classic and contemporary music
yeah a little bit of classical in there
too actually now yeah thinking about it
yeah so but you know it was neat you
know it's kind of like
it's about alien abduction it's about
psychic abilities
it kind of ties in with kind of like the
force it's kind of like
cosmic spirituality uh has like
uh kind of some of the questions that
kind of came from
the prometheus series you know uh about
you know do does the are the earth's
religions somehow tied in with aliens it
had all that
uh um kind of kind of motifs in it it
was good i liked it i want to say it had
like a little bit
um because at one point it even had like
some men in black conspiracy theories
yeah
they had like had a little bit of a
romancing the stone
kind of vibe like sometimes so it's you
could tell that the person that made
this
um eric demussy who directed it i think
this is if i'm not mistaken this is his
directorial debate debut he's actually a
special effects artist um
so i guess this is the first movie he
directed and even though
i don't know like maybe from the
description it sounds like it would be
kind of all over the place but it wasn't
really like that like it did kind of go
off tonally in a lot of directions
because like the first half of it is
basically
i mean the main character is uh named
isaac cyprus and he's like a
you know like a computer guy like at um
you know what is what does he do he's
like some kind of like a
number analyst or something like that at
uh the jet propulsion laboratory so he's
like a you know
math whiz he's like a big genius and
everything and at one point he's like
out
uh with his camera he's out hiking or
something like that and he
ostensibly gets kidnapped by aliens and
he gets it on film
so the first half of the movie is almost
kind of like this really fascinating
look into you know even if you have
footage of getting you know abducted and
you have footage of the alien and
everything like that how everybody just
thinks it's fake and it's like
and him trying to like connect to people
and like insist that he's telling the
truth so that was like really
interesting too
and but then it kind of about halfway
through the movie it kind of goes off in
a different
direction and becomes more of like like
you said like a thx
1138 or like romancing the stone or like
men in black or something like that
it kind of goes off in that like kind of
a more fun action oriented yeah
there are these androids are kind of
they're kind of like something out of
thx 11 38
they even used the exact same
motorcycles for
from this yeah it was it was uh yeah
obviously an homage
yeah i mean they were rd 350s with full
fairings on them you know what i mean
yeah
that's that's that's what they that's
what the robots from thx had
but they're white so they're kind of
like stormtroopers but they're androids
it's it's
it's quite cool you know and they can't
shoot either yeah it's just like
star wars [ __ ] gunfight scenes yeah
like you can tell around in a death star
with [ __ ]
princess leia and [ __ ] shooting you know
having to shoot out with the white
robots it's cool yeah you can tell that
the person that made this is really
really into like 80s
into into lucas lucas films and like
those kind of like
you know thrillers and adventure movies
like they came out in the 80s because
it's homaging like a lot of that stuff
but not in a really like obnoxious way
or anything this was actually
i ended up really really liking this
like i said a lot more than i was
expecting it to
i i was kind of expecting something more
like
close encounters like more like the
whole thing was going to be a drama
because that's kind of like what the
trailer was like it kind of portrayed it
as a drama
yeah and he knows it was like close
encounters he's giving you that vibe
he's playing games with you it's
good though yeah that's what i mean it
was a very deliberate homage to all of
them
lucas this is spielbergian lucasian
stuff
he knows the game that he's playing and
i mean the score of it was very
obviously
oh i made star wars it it wouldn't shock
me like if somebody told me hey john
williams did that score
i would not be in the least surprised
but then it breaks into rock music or
[ __ ] kind of some kind of industrial
music or whatever you know or classical
there's yeah like there's some new retro
wave
stuff in there too but it's like uh yeah
this was actually
a really lot of fun and for one that we
just kind of
saw you know i saw it randomly and
watched randomly because it looked the
trailer looked
decent it was new is this suggested as a
new movie on
x on xbox yeah so we saw it off xbox i
think
i think we rented it for like five bucks
yeah and you know
good movie man fun for the whole family
uh i think uh young people and old
people old people understand it i think
more than young people though young
people would dig it
you know i think what i did like about
it is that it's i wouldn't call this
like a modern movie a modern movie had a
bunch of tricky [ __ ] in it and kind of
like you know
uh weird ulterior motives this is just
they're just kind of playing it straight
the movie's actually about spirituality
it's very you know
if you're into cosmic spirituality you
know
and religion you'll like the movie
another one that this was like and i
think you mentioned this
to me earlier was cocoon a little bit of
a cocoon vibe
yeah as well uh i have to say this was
directed by
you know a special effects person so uh
the special effects were very good
especially like the alien spacecraft and
like the aliens themselves
looked really cool and uh you know it
was just really really cool it's like
like i said there was kind of something
in it for everybody it went off in a
bunch of different directions
but not in a way that was like super
chaotic or anything like that it was
just
to me it seemed like a pretty organic
yeah i bet this dude could have directed
star wars
better than the other well yeah maybe
you know how to put him on
on on you know instead of ryan johnson i
think this guy here
actually is uh you know the even uh the
dude who did uh force awakens what's his
name
jj abrams i think this guy was more
under would understand lucas and star
wars better than jj abrams even
yeah because this is the very least he
understands what it is
this was a very lucasy in film in a good
way yeah like you know what i mean
um but yeah this is you know a really
fun family oriented
sci-fi movie it's got some adventure in
it's got some drama in it's got some
cool special effects got some cool music
um you know so yeah they had to put this
guy on the mandalorian have him do some
mandalorian episodes yeah i wonder if he
i wonder if he has
like like i said i'm not entirely sure i
know he started out as a special effects
artist and this is i think this might be
his first
movie um but that's kind of like all i
know about them
but yeah so if you like sci-fi and you
like that kind of like 80s throwback
type of stuff uh you will probably enjoy
this uh as well so
like check it out
okay samurai marathon we rented this one
just kind of like on a whim the the it
looked pretty good in the trailers
we watched it and it's pretty good yeah
i liked it
it was uh it's like an american movie
wasn't it wasn't it
like half american and half japanese
yeah because it was directed by
um bernard rose who i'm not sure if he's
an american or he might be a brit
but um he directed the original candy
man uh he did
immortal beloved if you remember that
one with uh gary i think gary oldman was
in that yeah
um so he's he directed that and it's
weird because of just like
candyman this also had a score by philip
glass which is actually quite lovely
yeah um this is sort of based on i guess
it's based on a real
uh event which i had never actually
heard of
yeah it had to do with uh during the
time in japan where [ __ ]
uh commodore oliver perry kind of forced
his way
into japan to get them to open up and
start trading with the united states
it caused a lot of problems inside of
japan and one of the things that one of
the little side effects it
did is it caused some it caused the
japanese to actually
do a marathon because they were getting
soft they thought the samurai were
getting something
like whoever was like in charge of the
stamina this was in 1855
when when the whole samurai thing was
kind of on its way out i mean it was
almost the end of the future
samurai hadn't been at war for a long
long time and you know
japan was totally pacified they just sat
around reading books and drinking and
[ __ ]
you know they were bros they were just
yeah man samurai stuff man and then uh
yeah so uh dude made him [ __ ]
run a marathon and it caused a big
confusion
the the shogun thought it was an
uprising or a rebellion yeah and it
caused a bunch of problems
and then there were like spies inside
this one clan that was doing the
marathon that like
and they and they thought that it was
going to be an attack so they like said
to the shogun hey these guys are going
to attack you and then
like he had to go back and like
intercept the message and all this other
kind of [ __ ]
but it's basically i mean basically what
the guy said to him
um it was this one clan right of the
samurai
and the anaka clan i think it was called
they still do the uh the marathon to
this day so this is like the historical
thing that it was based on
and he basically came out and said you
know you're all a bunch of [ __ ]
you've all gone soft blah blah
he's like every samurai under the age of
50. tomorrow
you're gonna run a 36 mile marathon
yeah just so we can like you know see
that you're still in shape or whatever
yeah and samurais don't know how to run
they don't okay they run in a stylized
way
and there's even a name for it yeah they
said it in the movie i can't remember
what it is
i've noticed this you know because i
like samurai movies i've watched a lot
of them you know you know over the years
you know
and the japanese people from that era
did just they just didn't know how to
run they couldn't put
their feet out beyond a certain distance
in front of them
so it was just a bunch of little short
steps where the feet kicked up in the
back but they didn't go forward
uh there was a girl that was trying to
teach him how to run or like in the west
you have to actually
take a whole step and they were like
they wouldn't do it
i was like i didn't know if it was just
like a stylized thing or if it was just
because of the long skirts or what
no no it's just they weren't raised
running and they had a stylized way of
running it didn't work
you know it's just like little bitty
steps and the feet could only go back
they couldn't go in front of your pelvis
which you think you'd have to step
forward to run
i'm not even sure but they wouldn't step
forward they just and that you can see
it
in the movie you know and they even make
reference they make references to it
the movie because the girl is trying to
get them to like run like a western
person
run like a westerner because she was
she's like and she'd been to like um
holland or something like that she
wanted to like move to holland or
something or be a teacher or whatever
the hell she wanted to do
um so she was like up on the western
stuff and she was she was a princess i
think but she wanted to be in the
marathon too so she pretended she was a
boy
but um yeah so it's like this one i
think um
more compete it's not i don't want to
say it's a comedy it's just got a lot of
humor but it had a lot more humor in it
than a samurai movie would normally have
because like when they do the marathon
like obviously like some of the guys
that are like more out of shape are like
man [ __ ] the [ __ ] oh my back oh my god
oh my this and that and the other
and then um all the [ __ ] where because
if you won
um the dude would give you like whatever
you wanted
like yeah so everybody wanted to win
everybody there's like all these little
like um they're like threatening to take
one person out who's the fastest
together and break his legs there's like
one person who's like cheating he had
like a little
like cab or something like he would
stash it and then like go around and
stuff his phone like a rosie ruiz
yeah i've been watching a lot of samurai
movies you know over the years though
samurai movies did have a lot of comedy
that's true
it was more than a western yeah westerns
didn't have as much comedy
like you know the samurai movie is a
japanese equivalent to a [ __ ] cowboy
movie
yeah and uh cowboy movies tend to not
have a whole lot of humor in them
samurai movies kind of had
comedic relief in certain characters
there were a couple different kinds
a kurosawa flick was almost kind of like
psychedelic
imagine if like william shakespeare was
on acid
like that um some of the [ __ ] like a
zatuichi movie had comedy in it
yeah that's right that's true comedic
you know uh clownish characters in them
but it was just you know so but then
there were other ones that were just
really dry and deadpanned everything
totally
stylized and the people were like robots
or zombies and ever
they spoke only in real stylized ways
which
that that may have been pretty close to
the truth uh com
compa uh if if you know witnesses
western witnesses said that the japanese
people were very
odd when they first found them
everything was stylized and ritual
ritualized every little detail of what
they did so it might have been pretty
weird
uh to see and perf you know like we're
gothed out as [ __ ]
basically what you're talking about and
they had to do things in a certain way
like you know there was a way to drink
tea you know and there was a way to
[ __ ] come into a house and
there was a way to talk there was a way
to run
you know yeah so uh
but so it was i would say in terms of
the genre
now that was pretty pretty typical tone
for for the genre the action was good
costumes really good uh story was pretty
good
uh the the premise of the movie was
pretty interesting was it one of the
best samurai movies i've seen
no no uh i like him a lot more violent
than that
yeah there was like there was some
violence it was like a couple of
beheadings and like
people getting pushed off cliffs and
[ __ ] like that like when the race
started getting
you know there was some battles and
stuff but it was kind of mostly
i mean it was mostly about the race and
about like all the intrigue like
surrounding the race and like all the
misunderstandings about what was going
on and about the westerners coming and
wanting to trade and stuff
so i yeah so i wouldn't really call it
an action movie for me
i'm more like lone wolf and cub i like
that kind of [ __ ] baby cart to hell
yeah i mean
yeah i like that kind of samurai movie
yeah
but whereas this had elements of that
but it was more like a historical more
like a historical figure because like i
said it was based on
something that really happened yeah um
you know so even though there were
moments of violence in it like i said
there were fights and you know where
there was like attacks and
[ __ ] like that and uh you know
backstabbing with one with people trying
to win the race
and uh you know killing off people then
like you know so they wouldn't win and
[ __ ]
but um it's a good movie it was good
yeah and it is
it is new it's up there you can rent it
off of xbox i'm sure there's other
streaming
services i recommend it but if
you've never seen a samurai movie before
you really kind of want to see the lone
wolf and cub series i don't know if you
can stream it
there's three of them the three of them
are four of them well we have the set
don't we
yeah i have to go back and look again i
haven't seen him in so long yeah i'm
pretty sure there's i got the criterion
edition which is yeah
beautiful and i think it was nearly a
hundred bucks for that it was yeah it
was very for that for that
and but it's got had a whole bunch of
photographs and booklets in it
looks like it came out of damn feudal
japan the box and [ __ ]
uh you might be able to stream that you
want to see
the lone wolf and cub series which is
based on a manga or a comedy yeah
and it's [ __ ] bizarre but it's
action-packed
and you'll have a lot of fun with that
one yeah uh you i
recommend that one first for your first
samurai movie this is a little more
serious i would i would say yeah it has
humor in it but it's more of like i said
it's more of a drama it's not really an
action movie in the sense that there's
like sword fights every five minutes
it's not really like
no it's a lot of palace intrigue yeah
actually though
i'd have to say after you see lone wolf
and cub
his older brother the guy who stars in
that movie
is katsushin or shintaro katsu that's
but they
the japanese call him katsushin and he
he was zatoichi and that was
long running series you want to see
couples out to each of movies yeah there
was a [ __ ] ton of those yeah there's
like 26 of them
yeah it was 20 something he was about a
blind
yakuza who pretended to be a masseur
and but his cane in there he had hi in
there was a hidden sword
and he was you know fighting corrupt
samurai and fighting ninja and
fighting bad guys and standing up for
the little enough for the little guy
he's blind and
yeah it's that's the one you want that's
i'd rather
yeah i like a lot of those those are
better i haven't seen all of them
because there's so many but i have seen
it like there's been some zatuichi
reboots which for with new people
they're all in color and it's like i
think that was like in the 2000s
yeah you don't [ __ ] with that you want
to see the old zatuichi movies
from the sixties well i mean that guy is
zatui yeah shinto
katsu is [ __ ] i mean that made that
character yeah
it's like just like leonard nimoy made
[ __ ] spock
you want to see yeah yeah
but yeah so if you know if you like
samurai movies and you like historical
period dramas then yeah i imagine you'll
probably like this
yeah it's you know it's beautifully shot
like i said you know bernard rose is a
really good director and i've liked all
his other
movies a really nice score like i said
philip glass did it just like he did the
original candyman
uh so yeah it's streaming we have we run
it on xbox i'm sure you can
stream in other places
okay we saw a blood shot finally finally
saw a bloodshot
they wanted 19.99 for that we were
waiting for the price to go down because
it well it only played in the theater
because i remember seeing like the
[ __ ]
uh previews for what back when the
theaters were still open and it only
played in the theater for two weeks and
then everything got shut down and
everything like that so then they just
moved it to streaming that never started
playing in the theater
it did yeah it was it was in the theater
for a week or
maybe two weeks i just remember seeing
like the signs for it
yeah because i wanted to see it when we
had uh when we
when when we had amc yeah it was really
i don't think it ever opened it did it
really it was released
march 13th okay and then it played for
two weeks i think it played until the
24th and then they
like sent it to streaming okay um but
yeah for because for a while we wanted
to see it but you know because it looked
pretty decent but then
you know they kept wanting 20 bucks to
rent it and i'm like well let's wait
until the price goes yeah it finally
went down i think five bucks it was 5.99
5.99
yeah in in uh in all formats sd hd
and and then like ultra hd yeah and uh
so we saw it in hd and um it was good
it was not bad actually i was uh i i
really liked the riddick series
i thought riddick was a [ __ ] very vin
diesel
type [ __ ] series and i liked it and
then this one
came out and um watched it and it was
just
vin diesely as [ __ ] man [ __ ] it was
good even though he wasn't originally
the guy that they wanted in the main
character supposed to be jared leto yeah
but um
yeah this is based on the valiant comics
uh
you know comic book bloodshot this was
apparently supposed to be the first
they're doing they want to do like a
valiant comics cinematic
universe um there's another one called
harbinger that they want to do and they
want to do a crossover
i think originally they were going to do
harbinger first but then they decided to
do this one first is that the one that's
got the morbius
guy like the vampire no that's uh
that's marvel that's marvel dc or i
can't remember who that is
but this is a whole different this is a
whole different comics company um
this was so many pictures but they got
the rights to it and i think paramount's
gonna do harbinger if they still do it
um the sad thing about this is that this
movie i think it cost 45 million dollars
to make
and it was only out in the theater for a
couple of weeks um and i think so far
it's only made like
30 million back like from streaming and
everything even though it's like the top
streamed movie like on amazon prime and
all those other things
so you know it will remain to be seen
like how much money it's gonna make
yeah the world's changed though that
[ __ ] will be
up there streaming for [ __ ] ever it's
not like it was back in the day where
it it's got to make a certain amount of
money within a certain amount of time
or it's pulled from theaters yeah it's
not like that anymore that thing goes
people aren't in a hurry it'll sit up
there and make money for months and
months and months and months well
probably a lot of people were doing like
we were doing it wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait for
it to come down
from like 20 bucks yeah and then they'll
then they'll release it on
for sale on blu-ray guys will buy
[ __ ] blu-ray copies
i think the movie will do well last i
heard it was making good money
yeah on streaming well like i said it's
it was the number one streaming movie
okay um or at least in like the top five
it's just it hasn't made like its uh
budget back not yet
it probably will yeah it's because i
didn't hear anything about it
yeah so now that it's only 5.99 you'll
probably get some better word of mouth
that's what i'm thinking because it
i think it just went down like in the
last couple of days
so basically if i mean if you've read
the comic book
the weird thing about it and you said
this too it's like when it first
started yeah like the first five minutes
of it i'm going wow
we were kind of like not feeling it i
was waiting
jenny can jenny can attest i said this
[ __ ] at the time
i was waiting i was waiting for my boy
to [ __ ] i was waiting for sensei to step
out
stephen cigar at any moment i thought
steven seagal was gonna come and cross
slightly like that he'd come waddling
the shot yeah it just looked very kind
of
generic we're somewhere in the in a
middle eastern city
fighting these kind of generic you know
muslimy bad guys you know what i mean
yeah
everybody said that's what they were it
was just everything was kind of
they were were they in afghanistan no no
no well they shot this
yeah they were in india they were
shocked they shot this in south africa
though yeah i have to say
but the thing is is like so i wasn't
impressed that first four or five
minutes
but then he gets killed and he wakes up
and he's got all these nanites in them
and then
the story get gets better very quickly
and it gets a lot more colorful very
quickly
like the color palette changed man that
one scene where they were inside the
tunnel
like the truck and everything like that
that was super cool like the flares and
like the sides of like the blue police
lights and stuff that was like
yeah and the effects were good the
action was good
um the the tempo of the story was
was good they were controlling his mind
his memory was all [ __ ] up they could
reprogram his memory
he basically was a big pile of nanites
with just some flesh really
and they were constantly rebuilding him
every time he got shot so he could do he
basically and he ended up being very
similar to like the terminator out of
the t2
the liquid metal terminator he's kind of
like that but flesh because he could
like liquid
i think the only difference was that his
nanites had to be recharged periodically
so like if they went down to zero like
if his health went down to zero
he could die then he could like you know
they'd have to like i mean they'd bring
him back and [ __ ] but yeah so guy pierce
is in this [ __ ]
yeah um playing another role like he
played in all the [ __ ]
places he always plays these characters
but yeah so basically
it's because i don't think this is
really spoiling anything because they
basically said in the trailer
that you know vin diesel gets killed
like in the first 10 minutes of the
movie
along with his wife uh ostensibly
and um then he gets brought back by this
kind of high tech shadowy organization
shadowy military organization
corporation
who you know they have nanite technology
and he's like the first person that
they've actually
fully brought back from the dead like
there's a bunch of other people there
that have other
modifications and enhancements but he's
the first person that they've fully
brought back from the dead
and uh as the story goes on you find out
that some
of the [ __ ] that happened at the
beginning of the movie maybe wasn't
exactly how it happened and then there's
like some kind of like
shady [ __ ] going on with like who some
of these people were and like
how some of the people are alive some of
the people are dead you don't really
know
so i do feel like it takes a little bit
to get where it's going like you know
what i mean but once vin diesel gets
killed
and then the fun sci-fi part starts
yeah um it was actually a lot more
enjoyable yeah
it's it's it's an enjoyable movie it is
not deep
or by any you know it's not deep it's
not very complicated there are twists
and stuff
it's just a fun movie uh you know
they're trying to
compete with the marvel universe and
give you but give you
you know a slightly different experience
which i i think it succeeded at that
like i would watch another one i'd watch
this one again yeah this is
this is a very interesting uh you know
universe that they could expand out
good effects cool [ __ ] happened yeah i
really like like all the nanite effects
like when he look when he gets hurt and
like has them come sucking back into his
body
yeah the only downside is is that with
these movies this this goes for all
these movies like this
they're so effects
heavy that you almost become immune to
to all the imagery it doesn't matter
what they show you you're just like yeah
okay
oh yeah yeah okay it doesn't it ceases
it's
it almost overloads your system yeah to
where
it ceases to impress you anymore you
just take it for granted that you're
seeing this [ __ ] badass well that's
kind of
that's kind of what happened to me with
the marvel movies i mean they're good
movies but
you get to a point and and the thing the
sad thing about it is that
at this point i think like that ship is
probably sailed because everybody knows
how good cgi can be yeah and
they can essentially make put anything
i'll show you
anything and i think everybody knows
that now it's almost like that [ __ ]
needs to wear off by now
yeah like i want to stop seeing stop i
don't want to see things anymore
i don't want to see i don't want to see
things anymore
just for a while so then after a while
you can appreciate it again
right yeah like how cool it looks yeah i
don't want to see things anymore just
do some [ __ ] i don't know
but yeah i can't describe it but i think
you know what i'm talking i mean i still
get impressed with like
when [ __ ] is done practically that's
what it impresses me like
in like in mad max fury road for example
or like some horror movies that have
some of the bond films like some [ __ ]
up practical effects or stunts or
anything that is actually a lot more
impressive to me than uh cgi is because
cgi it's just like somebody sitting at a
computer building like ta-da
yeah i had a feeling that this was kind
of a mixture of the two i think some of
the vehicle wrecks were real
but there was they did look
it is what it is it's a marvel type
movie
yeah and i and i think it's a comic book
style movie not not quite as comic book
it's a little more realistic
yeah than the marble map vin diesel
actually acted in this
there was this he did i saw it yeah you
saw it
there was a scene where he was trying to
get back with his girlfriend and i
believed him
yeah i believe that he was heartbroken
yeah and
that's what i mean i saw it you saw it
and i said i said you see it
yeah because normally vin diesel is just
playing vin diesel he's just being as
diesel easy
but he did a good job but he he was
actually acting
so you know and it i it was kind of like
when arnold actually acts
yeah you go damn arnold [ __ ] acted
yeah it's like
it's it's just funny to see them because
i guess it's different than like other
big muscle guys like the rock who is
actually like really charismatic and
he's so he always acted and he's always
because he seems like a regular dude
but people like arnold schwarzenegger
vin diesel and stuff like that their
whole thing is like being big muscly
like stoic
dudes yeah and you don't usually see
them show much emotion
they're always that same character
they're always kind of cute they're
always playing
arnold or he's playing vin yeah you know
which that works for me i mean i can
understand it you know
i'll watch an arnold move to see arnie i
watch a ven diesel move to see
van diesel i think most people do and
you know what i mean and i
and like i said the [ __ ] i love the
riddick series i thought that was
[ __ ] badass i thought he was great in
it
these this movie here i almost want to
say
i almost have i'm almost tempted to say
that this might be his best movie
it might be i haven't seen like a [ __ ]
ton of his movies yeah
he's not as big as i remembered him did
he get a little bit smaller
he's honestly no i don't remember it
doesn't really matter i'm not you know
i'm not i'm not being sizest
and i'm judging a man for his size he
wasn't as big as i remembered him but he
still looked good he was in good shape
yeah it's in good shape um but i think
i think this might be his best movie
some people will go well of course the
special effects were superior i'm not
i'm not even talking about the special
effects
yeah just talking about the acting and
um the story and
just the overall tone and cadence of the
cadence of the movie this might i don't
i think the riddick movies are hard to
beat i mean i mean they're just kind of
for me they're classics but yeah
this might be his best movie i don't you
know i i don't have
when i got done watching the movie i did
not have the feeling that i was watching
the last
vin diesel movie yeah you know what i
mean sometimes you get the feeling like
ah that didn't that didn't work
yeah i think i got the feeling of like
oh i'll probably see another one of
these
yeah well like i said that's what
they've actually
um as far as i know i don't know if this
is going to fall through or not but they
had contractually they were going to do
five movies in this like valiant comics
universe
they were going to do like a expanded
universe type thing like marvel even
even if amc goes under and theaters
don't really come back in big numbers
they'll just adjust the budget and
adjust the weight just make smaller
budgets
just yeah and send them to streaming
it'll be just like what netflix does
you don't need to [ __ ] make put 100
million dollars in a [ __ ] movie
that's all bloat and p and [ __ ]
people paying their
buddies and [ __ ] [ __ ] money
laundering well and a lot of it too is
trying to get like big name actors you
know and their huge salaries
so one you only need one and maybe this
will give like smaller
actors or like you know lesser known
actors like to get a chance in there
because you know they're more affordable
than like some of the other ones and you
just make movies that are just more
economically efficient yeah i mean and
and
so i kind of you'll you'll see more of
these i think this one will i think this
one was
an artistic success and i think it
it did what i think bloodshot did
what they wanted it to do it was the
movie that they wanted
yeah i believe this you know what i mean
i believe they walked away happy from
this one
when it was done yeah i think it will
make money over time
i mean this was this was this guy's
first uh
directing job david s f wilson uh the
writer on it was actually the same
writer as
fantasy island i don't know if that
tells you anything jeff wallow
but you know what fantasy island got
panned but me and jenny liked it it was
an entertaining movie to watch
it was yeah it was all right it's just
you just watched it
you watched that [ __ ] on a list and you
went to amc and you watched it that [ __ ]
just [ __ ] laughed at it yeah
that's all it was it's just fun it
wasn't terrible it was just you know but
there's
some parts i liked better than others i
have to say about bloodshot though the
guy that stole the movie
was the dude that played the scientist
and then wilford wiggins
yeah that dude was a riot yeah
i loved that guy i would watch a whole
movie about that guy
everybody everybody in the movie did a
good job yeah but he was my favorite
yeah because he was just like the
funniest and he doesn't even come into
it until like the end
and i was like i'm kind of hoping if
they do an expanded universe like
they'll do a movie about him
or he'll be like in other ones because
he was like he was [ __ ] great
but yeah this is like a completely
decent movie and like i said um i'm not
sure about other streaming platforms but
on the uh
xbox it just went down to six dollars
for
high definition and 4k yeah i think
now's the time's gonna start making its
money
so yeah if you want to check it out uh
now's the time to do it because it just
went down cheaper so check it out